-Our next guest is the reigning
ACM New Female Artist
of the Year.
Performing her new single,
"Heart Like a Truck,"
give it up for Lainey Wilson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I never stay
in one place too long ♪
♪ The dirt road's singin' me
a siren's song ♪
♪ I gotta find a field ♪
♪ I need to spin my wheels ♪
♪ I got a hankerin'
for four wide tires ♪
♪ And I can't help it,
it's the way I'm wired ♪
♪ Boy, you get too close ♪
♪ Boy, you need to know ♪
♪ I got a heart like a truck ♪
♪ It's been drug
through the mud ♪
♪ Runs on dreams and gasoline ♪
♪ And that old highway
holds the key ♪
♪ It's got a lead foot down
when it's leavin' ♪
♪ Lord knows it's taken
a hell of a beatin' ♪
♪ A little bit of love
is all that it's needin' ♪
♪ But it's good as it is tough ♪
♪ I got a heart like a truck ♪
♪♪
♪ There ain't no brakin'
when I throw it in drive ♪
♪ Don't always keep it
in between the lines ♪
♪ If you're a ready for a ride ♪
♪ Pedal-down state of mind ♪
♪ Boy, I tell you what,
you better buckle up ♪
♪ I got a heart like a truck ♪
♪ It's been drug
through the mud ♪
♪ Runs on dreams and gasoline ♪
♪ And that old highway
holds the key ♪
♪ It's got a lead foot down
when it's leavin' ♪
♪ Lord knows it's taken
a hell of a beatin' ♪
♪ A little bit of love
is all that it's needin' ♪
♪ But it's good as it is tough ♪
♪ I got a heart like a truck ♪
♪♪
♪ Go on and see if you can
knock off the dust, yeah ♪
♪ Shine it up, rev it up,
and let it run, yeah ♪
♪ It gets a high ridin' off
into the sun, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ I got a heart like a truck ♪
♪ It's been drug
through the mud ♪
♪ Runs on dreams and gasoline ♪
♪ And that old highway
holds the key ♪
♪ It's got a lead foot down
when it's leavin' ♪
♪ Lord knows it's taken
a hell of a beatin' ♪
♪ A little bit of love
is all that it's needin' ♪
♪ But it's good as it is tough ♪
♪ I got a he-a-a-a-a-art ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ Like a truck ♪
♪♪
♪ Go on and see if you can
knock off the dust, yeah ♪
♪ Shine it up, rev it up,
and let it run, yeah ♪
♪ It gets a high ridin' off
into the sun, yeah ♪
into the sun ♪
[ Finale plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]